You know that slimy,
gross blob of green
you get caught in
when you go swimming
in a lake or a pool
that needs cleaning?
That stuff is the best!
Hey peeps.
Trace here, coming
at you from D News.
How do you feel about algae?
Ambivalent, right?
I used to be like
that, but no longer.
I am on board.
I think algae is great, and
I don't care who knows it.
Algae is amazing.
Algae is a blanket term for a
large group of plants ranging
from single-celled
simple organisms
to giant kelps and seaweeds.
Algae use chlorophyll to
produce energy and exhale
oxygen, which is great for us.
But they can also be used for a
ton of other fantastic things.
One major thing is algae could
be used to produce biofuel.
Back in the spring, the Journal
of Environmental Science
and Technology published
a study showing algae
could be used to produce 25
billion gallons of biofuel
annually in the
United States alone,
without stressing
our water resources.
Well, that's only
one-twelfth of the way
to getting us off
fossil fuels altogether.
This is just algae,
pond scum, slime.
You might think oh, man, this
biodiesel from algae thing
is super complicated.
But in reality, they put algae
in a press and squeeze it.
Boom.
Oil.
Honestly.
That's a lot like
an olive press.
It gets 75% of the
efficiency of the algae.
But by adding chemicals
to the process,
we can get up to 100% of
that oil out of the product.
And that's not all algae can do.
In Hamburg, Germany, a
15-unit apartment building
is powered by giant
tanks of algae
that's living there
on the exterior.
The plants keep the
building cool in the summer
and insulate in the winter.
Excess heat is funneled into
saline tanks to be used later.
But that's not all.
When the algae is grown enough,
it's harvested from the tanks
and put into a biomass
processor in the basement
to be used to
power the building.
You don't want to
make power from algae?
That's OK.
How about street lamps?
Yep.
A French biochemist named
Pierre Calleja talked about it
at Ted X earlier this year.
The plan would be to use this
CO2-sucking, energy-producing
algae to make oxygen
and energy, but also
use that extra energy to make
their bio-luminescence light
the streets at night.
It's still conceptual, but aside
from imagining a city bathed
in an otherworldly
green awesomeness,
you could just get
the street lamps
and put it on your own head.
This is freaky as
hell, but maybe could
be the future perhaps, maybe?
Maybe?
I don't know.
This is some kind of
dystopian, Promethean
strangeness, you guys.
The little tubes are filled
with algae that feed on the CO2
exhaled by the
wearer and the light
hitting the thin tubes
from the outside.
And when the wearer
needs a meal,
he or she can just suck
some of that algae right
into their bodies.
The plants are
nutritious, though I
wouldn't say delicious.
Not that I've tried them,
except for that one summer
at the lake, but
that was an accident.
Currently the suit,
designed by Burton Nitta,
is relegated to the realm of
strange things, but who knows.
If a food crisis hits, we
might be willing to try it.
Algae, respect.
Nice job.
Keep up the good work, man.
So what do you think?
Would you wear the suit,
live in the apartment,
power your car with
this little organism?
Tell us about it in
the comments below,
and click that subscribe
button to keep us powered
and serving you more
D News every day.